ja ich freue mich heute als
gesprächspartner hätten prozent öfter
bei mir zu haben im studio und wir
wollen uns heute über dem griff der
lebensform und erhalten
der schöpfer woher kommt denn eigentlich
der begriff lebensform was hat jetzt
eine geschichte ja vielleicht fange ich
weil damit an zu sagen was eigentlich
lebensraum ist denn das ist ja doch
einen sehr sprechender ausdruck
lebensformen die lebensform das ist die
form eines lebens also das ist die form
von uns allen lebewesen sind und das ist
etwas was über das einzelne lebewesen
hinausweist insofern ist das bezeichnet
was wir mit anderen gemeinsam haben also
wir können eben von der menschlichen
lebens form sprechen und wir können von
lebensformen bei tieren sprechen wir
können insgesamt sagen erst mal dass
alle tiere eine lebensform im
unterschied zu der lebensraum des
menschen haben und dieser begriff ist
sehr alt er doch schon 16 jahrhundert
auf dann bezogen auf den menschen
gewinnt dann aber so mit dem entstehen
der biologie frühen neunzehnten
jahrhundert an bedeutung und zwar vor
allen dingen in der unterscheidung von
verschiedenen stufen des lebendigen also
man unterscheidet niedere und höhere
lebensformen man unterscheidet eine
gesunde von einer kranken lebensform
oder auch die lebensform der pflanzen
von der lebensform der tiere also man
denkt in form einer skala natur aber so
richtig zu einem biologischen begriff
wird er erst am ende des jahrhunderts
man kann sagen als gegenbewegung quasi
zur evolutionstheorie weil er nämlich
eine ganz eigene eine andere
klassifikation von lebewesen ermöglicht
also nicht im rahmen von verwandtschaft
zusammenhängen von stammbäumen sondern
im rahmen von dem was eben die einzelnen
lebewesen miteinander verbinden es als
der lebensform begriff hat ein begriff
der der ökologie zu bewirken ist ja
genau das ist der kontext in dem er
ursprünglich terminologie verwendet
wurde wie gesagt ist ja vorher auch
schon aufgetaucht wie der ausdruck aber
so in terminologischen verwendung im
sinne eines terminus der biologie ist er
von ökologen geprägt worden von pflanzen
ökologen im besonderen nämlich von
genius warm in einem dänischen pflanzen
ökologen der bezieht den ausdruck auf
wuchsformen vegetations formen von
pflanzen ganz bekannt für alle die sich
mit biologie beschäftigt haben auch
sicherheit bekannt sie ist sind die
lebensform typen von round care
das sind lebensformen von pflanzen auch
wiederum die sich auf die lage der
übersäuerung knospen beziehen also ob
die pflanze widrige lebensumstände also
den winter als samen überwintert oder
knochen von knollen unter der erde oder
eben die bäume oberhalb der erde also
das sind einfache vorstellung von wegen
von lebensformen dass man so
integrationsfirmen denkt wie auch schon
alexander von humboldt das getan hat
also bald wieder weg kräuter von
sträuchern und bäumen unterscheidet das
sind lebensformen der pflanzen und der
begriff ist dann aber auf einen anderen
ökologen zwanzigsten jahrhundert auf
tiere übertragen worden so dass man von
der lebensform auch raubtieren
beispielsweise sprechen kann
der lebensraum der flugtiere aber das
interessante dabei ist eben dass dieser
begriff eine klassifikation ermöglicht
eine gegenüberstellung von verschiedenen
typen des lebens ist lebendig sein die
unabhängig von
verwandtschaftsbeziehungen also wir
haben diesen begriff der säugetiere
beispielsweise dass es eben nicht eine
lebensform primär sondern solche tiere
sind eine katholische gruppe für
zoologen also die haben einen
gemeinsamen vorfahren und diese
säugetiere können aber sehr
unterschiedliche lebensformen verfassen
also wir kennen solche tiere als tiere
die auf dem land leben mit vier beinen
und wir kennen aber auch solche die
fliegen können wie fledermäuse und das
sind eben sehr unterschiedliche
lebensformen und wir kennen auch
säugetiere die im wasser lebende die
bahn und diese doch sehr
unterschiedliche formen sein leben zu
führen und alle haben viel mit fischen
gemeinsam deswegen sie eben auch auswahl
frischer bezeichnet werden und das zu
bezeichnen also diese gemeinsamkeiten
die fische mit wahl fischen haben
dafür ist der berühmte lebensform sehr
geeignet das ist dann sozusagen queer
auch durch die gattungen hindurch und
hat säugetiere und sagen wir auch im
extremfall insekten die gemeinsame
formen des lebens teilen die damit zur
selben lebensform zu gehören
ja genau genau wir haben gesetze frage
wie kann man denn dann die lebensform
begriff auf den menschen beziehen wie
würden sie das versuchen zu erklären aus
philosophischer sicht was halten sie
davon
attraktiv ja das ist ein etwas anderer
begriff also der begriff der lebensform
ist ja in den letzten jahren sehr stark
aufgenommen werden oder man kann nicht
sagen aufgenommen worden sondern ist
stark gemacht worden
also immer vollkommen ablehung von der
biologischen tradition also er ist quasi
neu geprägt worden
von philosophen die mit ihm speziell die
dasein weise des menschen fassen wollen
also die auch verstehen wollen was das
heißt es sein leben zu führen als ein
mensch und was hat das möglicherweise
für ethischen implikationen und dabei
kommen sie eben auf merkmale die das ist
sogar auf einer historischen ansatzes
auf merkmale die menschen gemeinsam sind
die quasi typisch sind für diese viel
für das menschliche die sinnlichkeit
sinnliche wahrnehmung oder das
kommunizieren auch gedächtnis und
konzentrationsfähigkeit das sind so
momente die philipper fort die dafür
bekannt ist für diesen ansatz nennt und
die sie zusammen fast unter dem
schlagwort ergebnis also es folgt etwas
daraus man kann aus diesem wenn man das
festhält als merkmal das menschliche
kennzeichnen kann man daraus ableiten
dass es heißt ein gutes leben zu führen
und ein ein mensch zu sein der diese
dinge instanziert die für diese
lebensform typisch sind und dann soll
eben aus diesem typischen auch etwas
normatives von man kann eben dann sagen
das ist defizitär weil es diese
lebensform nicht in gänze instanzen
das wäre ein übergang vom seien auch
schulden oder von der natur auf sollen
wie stehen sie zu diesem übergang von
ihrer perspektive als naturphilosoph als
versuch der biologie
ich halte das für einen interessanten
ansatz dass mit dem begriff der form der
lebensform und speziell zu versuchen das
ist natürlich immer eine herausforderung
diese diese brücke diese kluft vom saal
vom sein sollen zu schlagen
ich erhalte da erst mal interessanter
ansatz aber ich sehe auch probleme das
gerade wenn man so wie philipp erfurt
oder auch mal thompson das versuchen
wollen
da sehe ich noch durchaus begründung
bedarf denn also thompson macht es ja
mit naturhistorischen urteilen sagt die
sind naturhistorische world teile die
wir beispielsweise einem einem einem rot
lux das ist ein beispiel
[Musik]
demgegenüber fällen dass wir sagen wir
können dieses leben kann nicht anders
beschreiben als wenn wir auf begriffe
der lebensformen zurückgreifen und
sprechen von einem standard der gesetzt
wird für diese art des des luchses roth
luxus und also da werden auch lebensform
für jede einzelne tierart definiert das
ist interessant aber ich sehe noch nicht
wirklich inwiefern dieses typologische
denken was ich daran auch verankert sehe
das also jeder tierart ein typus
zugeordnet wird
inwiefern dieses eine normative kraft
entwickeln sollte
denn heutzutage als evolutionsbiologe
denken wir doch meistens in form von
variationen und in form von populationen
die einfach eine vielfalt von typen
enthalten und inwiefern ein typus
normative kraft entfalten sollte als das
für die art repräsentative und
verbindliche das scheint mir doch eher
der naturgeschichte des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts verwurzelt zu sein
verpflichtet zu sein als einer
klinischen evolutionstheorie die
heutzutage für denken im rahmen von der
philosophie und hinter gebe ja vielen
dank für ihr gespräch gesehen ist es
noch viel zu tun
zum thema sein und sollen natur und
normativität vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit